This is just a piece of paper
that means absolutely nothing.
That is my bachelor's degree.
Um, I graduated with honors.
As to opens up a discussion on,
does Education Equal Success or make you smart?
Think everyone should be educated
and have a very rigorous education.
But the matter of reality today
is that colleges are not a place of, um,
rigorous education anymore.
The saying when I was in college was these
get degrees,
see, is get degrees.
You can do bare minimum.
As long as you're not failing,
you can get your degree.
Ask the question,
do you need college
if you wanna be a traditional wife,
a homie, etcetera?
I would say no.
Now, if you wanna go into a field
where you actually do need a degree,
like nursing
or what I was going for, um,
or like, medical things, then, yes,
there's a lot of things in college that you
don't actually need a degree for.
College is a big excuse to party and live it up.
And I think it is very detrimental in your young 20s
when you should be laying the foundation
for the rest of your life and being productive
instead of sleeping around on weekends
and getting belligerently drunk at bars.
Anyways, don't let anyone make you feel bad
if you don't wanna go to college.